they look alike they dress alike
two identical beauties but one of them
has the very devil inner
[Music]
[Laughter]
and it's us again it's episode 61 of the
13 o'clock podcast and today we're kind
of revisiting something we did a while
back sort of remember before when we did
the like crazy brothers kind of show
with like the hoarders and the creepy
gynecologist that that David Kruger Park
movie was based on dead ringers okay
we're doing another one kind of like
that but these are two sets of twins and
these are two weird creepy as [__]
stories I mean these I've been wanting
to do these for a long time because this
[__] is this is some crazy [__] yeah
it's kind of there's some mystery
involved with these yeah these are two
very very weird stories these are both
sisters not brothers but yeah so these
are two kind of well-known twin stories
and we're gonna get into them in a
little bit super weird and creepy but
first we have some housekeeping to do as
usual my latest book the faceless
villain which is a true a true crime
compilation covering unsolved murders
from 1900 to 1959 it's Volume one and it
is out now in print and ebook version
and the audiobook version I'm putting
the finishing touches on the sound
editing and I will get that uploaded
sometime in the next week so we'll
probably be like two weeks before it's
live because it takes such a long time
to go through quality control and all
that business so it will be available in
a couple of weeks and after it goes live
then I will have twenty five codes for
free downloads and a couple of you have
already approached me about wanting
copies and I have taken down your name
so when it comes out you know you'll get
one if you want one let me know and like
I said it'll be two weeks at least two
and a half weeks something like that and
you have to promise to write a review
for Amazon or for audible or whatever
and then I will give you one it doesn't
have to be super long it doesn't have to
be anything like that but you do have to
write a review for it and I will give
you a free code and you can listen to it
for free yeah so if you want in on that
just let me know and there's a chance
after spooky Empire that we might
be able to hand out some books yeah we
were thinking about doing that - because
spooky Empire um as we mentioned before
is coming up to 27th 28th and 29th read
a horror convention here in Orlando
Florida and we are going to be there all
three days we're going to be helping the
sick and twisted panel on Friday evening
and we'll be on a bunch of the other
panels I'm on a twin peaks' one on
Sunday and there's a couple of other
ones so we're gonna be there all three
days we're gonna be there selling books
and signing books and all this other
kind of business so if you want to drop
by and see as you can now if we have any
books left over because I bought some to
sell at the convention if we have some
left over we might be doing like kind of
giveaway or sign books or something like
that yeah they'll be autographed so yeah
we can autograph him and send him to you
if you want one so we'll see yeah we're
you know we'll have to see how many we
have left over yeah they went outside
about it is that if we do that you write
a review you're not really like a
verified purchaser yes kind of like yeah
they're weird about that and the Amazon
is weird about that yeah so I'm not I
wish I wish we could give out direct
samples free yeah the books and the
ebooks and stuff like that print books
yeah yeah it seems like a good system
that they have with the audiobooks even
though it's all under the Amazon
umbrella I don't know why they don't do
all of it but whatever but you know
that's how that goes so you know there
there'll be plenty of opportunities for
you to read the book if you want to read
it and let's see what else if you didn't
notice we put up our latest movie review
which was ex calibre just put that up a
couple of days ago so go check that out
if you haven't heard it yet also check
out our patreon of course which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast and
if you want to give a monthly donation
you can if you would rather give a
one-time donation then you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a little link
on the sidebar to a PayPal where you can
give some money and I also want to give
a shout out to Dean one of our youtube
listeners who gave us another donation
yes so thank you very much it is much
appreciated it's donations like this
that keep this show going yeah and you
know help us out with all our various
things that you need to do for your fans
please consider becoming a patron yeah
it really does happen you can give as
little as like $2 or
you know yeah any amount any amount is
good so yeah shout out for that now for
our for Dean and for our $10 up patrons
on patreon we're doing another Google
hangout it will probably be this coming
weekend which is I mean they're gonna do
it the 21st to the 22nd Saturday or
Sunday because we can't do it the last
weekend because we'll be it's boot camp
fire so we won't be home but um so you
know we had a good time last time and
hopefully we'll get some more people
just drop by this time and hang out with
us for an hour to talking about whatever
just shootin the [__] yeah whatever you
want to talk about if you want to ask us
some questions personal questions
they'll be able to give you a drink
probably too well you'll have a drink in
that package Frank if you just watch
each other drinking they would just sit
over the screen yeah that would actually
be fun you should probably do that and
the only other thing I want to say is
that if you want to contribute a story
to our Halloween special which will be
coming up on Halloween obviously then
you can still do that either email them
to grave cake at gmail.com I'll put a
link in the description or you can just
contact the 13 o'clock podcast Facebook
page or whatever and I'll try to get
back to you on that we have several very
good contributions that are going to be
on the show but we could always use more
so if you want to do that you're kind of
running out of time so you might want to
do that in the next week or two so I'm
just saying if you want to do that and
it doesn't like I said then have to be a
paranormal or anything like that just a
scary creepy story that happened to you
or happen to somebody you know as long
as it's true to the best of your
knowledge then we'll put it on the show
and it'll be a fun Halloween special and
that'll be that now let's get to the
topic at hand
we call this twins of Terror which I
guess sort of applies to both cases I
don't really want to it's funny because
there was actually the first case I'm
gonna talk about is called the silent
twins their names are actually June and
Jennifer Gibbons and it's weird because
I saw this documentary about them that
was made for a show I guess it's on that
Criminal Investigation Network on
discovery or whatever it's called evil
twins and I said well I don't know if I
would go
so far as to call the Gibbons twins evil
they were for sure mentally disturbed
probably they didn't kill anybody or
anything like that but their story is
pretty weird were they from well they
were actually born in Barbados but when
they were small their family their dad
was in the Air Force I think and he got
transferred to this little bitty town in
Wales called Haverfordwest so they moved
there when the girls were very little
now what ended up happening there I mean
they seemed like fairly normal babies
you know as far as twins go I've always
found twins like really fascinating I
have a couple sets in my mom's side of
the family but you know they're normal
or everything like that but I always
thought it was I always thought it was
like so fascinating like what would it
be like it was something that I thought
of a lot as a kid because you know
because a couple my cousins they're
twins I have a twin of you see yeah to
have like another one of you cuz there
are essentially clones is what they are
same DNA yeah they have the same DNA and
and I mean even though genetically
they're identical I mean obviously
there's kind of a bell curve of like
some of some twins that are even though
they're genetically identical they're a
lot more similar than some that you know
that are kind of different from each
other the weird thing about these two
they seem fairly normal when they were
babies now they got moved to this little
bitty town in Wales and evidently this
is kind of where the trouble started
because this small town it was very
white and um you know these two girls
were black okay so there was kind of a
lot of you know racism going on at the
time like I said this is a very small
town I was very white it was like out in
the middle of nowhere and when these
girls went to school I mean they seemed
like they had been kind of reserved
prior to that you know they were very
close obviously as twins tend to be but
when they went to school and started
getting bullied by the other children
because they were different it seems
like it kind of made them withdraw more
into each other's company
this is some
sanity's yeah and it was about this time
here's the thing the documentary that I
saw about them that was called evil
twins now they said that the girls had a
speech impediment now that's the only
place that I've ever heard that said
every other source that I've seen about
them said they didn't have a speech
impediment but they had a very strong
Creole accent and they spoke very good
English but they spoke very very quickly
right so they had kind of a weird like
pidgin kind of language that only each
other understood right which happens a
lot with with twins they develop their
own secret language and some people that
heard it said it sounded kind of
bird-like and stuff like that so because
they were at school and they wouldn't
really talk to anyone except each other
and then when they talked to each other
it was this weird unintelligible kind of
language and also they tended to their
actions like mirrored each other like
they would sit in the cafeteria and they
would eat but they you know they would
raise their Forks in their mouth and eat
like simultaneously right and when they
walked they would walk like one behind
the other and their foot movements were
like matched each other but they would
walk super super slow they'd walk slowly
but it's dead right oh so yeah so it was
kind of eerie like they had like a
reenactment on this documentary it
looked pretty creepy so I can see why
like obviously I'm not justifying these
horrible [__] children that bullied
them because they got worse you know the
more they got bullied because it was
kind of like a feedback loop because
there's like you know
well you're black so we'll pick on you
oh but then you start acting weirder and
then we'll pick on you even more yeah
and apparently you know they got beat up
they got all this other kind of stuff
and it's kind of sad because the school
administrators didn't really know what
to do about it like they didn't really
do much about it all they would do was
kind of let the girls go home early just
so the other kids wouldn't like lie and
wait for them like on the way on their
way home to like kick their asses or
whatever and that was kind of all they
did so you know as time went on they got
put into I mean their parents didn't
really know what
do with them because they were getting
more and more withdrawn and eventually
they got moved to another school which
was more for you know kids with the you
know developmental problems and things
like that now it should be noted that
when these girls were given an IQ test
they were extremely intelligent and you
can actually tell that from a lot of
their Diaries and stuff like that that
you could read later on I mean even when
they were teenagers the stuff they were
writing and their Diaries and stuff like
that was very adult hmm
and they seemed to have like a lot of
insight into their own behavior and into
each other's behavior because they had
like this weird kind of symbiotic like
love-hate kind of relationship they were
almost like two halves of one person
like they almost kind of like they
couldn't be one complete person man yeah
and it was kind of oh it's kind of a
weird situation
so they got sent to this other school it
was seemed like a little bit better but
then the psychiatrists were working with
them and said you know maybe it would be
better if they were separated because
you know they seem so you know locked
into each other and like no one can no
one else can really penetrate into their
this world that they've created so they
had the idea that maybe we should
separate them so they separated them and
they both immediately went into
catatonia and the odd thing was that
sometimes they would find the girls in
the same position but later like at
opposite ends of the building like they
would both be sitting in the same
position looking at how could they know
I don't know but they did they're
genetically programmed yeah there that
was kind of like what their what their
thing was and the thing about them too
is that they seemed I mean nowadays it
does kind of seem like their behavior
seems kind of like schizophrenia a bit
but I don't know if they diagnosed them
with that at the time I think they might
have speculated that it might have been
that later they did try to help them I
mean they did put them in another school
and stuff like that but it didn't really
seem to be all that effective now when
they turned 15
they decided because in the UK you know
you turn 15 or 16 you can leave school
if you want to you don't just stay till
you're 18 like you do in the u.s. you
know or at least that's how it was then
I'm not sure how it is anymore but um
but so they opted to leave school after
that they pretty much just locked
themselves in their bedroom and would
not come out they stopped talking to
their parents they stopped talking to
their siblings and basically they just
sat in their room and they started to
write if not write plays but they
started to act out plays they had all
these dolls and they would make the
dolls talk to each other and they would
like reenact these really like operatic
violent sort of scenarios with these
dolls and most of the stuff they came up
with date for some reason they were
super fascinated with the United States
and particularly American teenagers yeah
they were super fascinated with like
Malibu and like the whole California
kind of thing and even though they'd
never been there they were also super
fascinated with crime and criminals and
they seemed very seduced by like this
kind of crazy criminal behavior and so
after they were their mom you know she
would have to like bring food and like
leave it in the hallway and stuff like
that because they wouldn't come out and
their mom thought well maybe they need
like another creative outlet so she gave
them some Diaries and they started
writing in the Diaries and they said the
weird thing was that they wrote like
tiny tiny tiny they said it was like six
lines in one line of the diary you know
and then like Adelaide yet so there's
tiny tiny writing and they wrote and
wrote and wrote there was just Diaries
and there's full and they wrote books
they were novels they were all this kind
of stuff yeah and they said the weird
thing about it and they actually sent
out like some of their stories and
novels and stuff to get published of
course they all got rejected because
apparently they were super super weird
right and like one of the girls were at
one called disco mania there was like
about this it was about like a nightclub
that made people like I don't know what
it was in there but it made people go
insane and like go super violent
everything like that and but like I said
they were super into like all of their
stories like ended badly like with some
kind of crying death or dismemberment or
something like whatever you need to
stuff survives I think it does yeah if
you were to make a movie based on their
writings I would love to see that
actually publish it yeah I would be
curious to read it like I believe
there's only like little excerpts that I
could find online like excerpts of their
Diaries and things like that yes so
apparently they just wrote these really
weird things about crime and stuff like
that now when they got a little bit
older they met these American boys that
were living in Wales they were teenagers
too I don't know how much older they
were than the girls and they apparently
started sort of a weird relationship
with these three guys they had sex with
them they started doing drugs apparently
these guys were like not a super good
influence because you know they were
petty criminals and stuff like that but
that's kind of what fascinated the girls
about about these guys so there was kind
of like a weird thing going on there for
a while then the boys had to go back to
the u.s. like they moved away and
evidently June and Jennifer were really
upset about this and it kind of all
happened that after the boys moved away
all their novels and stuff like that
like all these stories they've been
working on rejected and it almost seemed
like they had this very strange
grandiose kind of idea that they needed
to be heard they wanted the world to
know who they were you know what I mean
and I think they thought that they imeem
they wanted to get that through their
writing but since they couldn't get that
then they decided to do it through crime
instead so basically they got together
and decided that they wanted to do a
spree of some sort so they and they
originally started breaking and entering
you know the weird thing too is that
they would just go they would break in
buildings you should break the window
steal a bunch of [__] and then they
would call the cops and say hey we just
broke into this place blah blah blah and
then they would hang up right and they
didn't get caught for a while was
released her they actually take stuff
yeah yeah I think they were kind of like
got kind of a charge out of that so then
they decided that they were gonna
graduate to arson so they started so
they start going around Wales setting
[__] on fire and they actually burned
down several buildings at about a
hundred thousand pounds worth of damage
yeah and they did that a bunch of times
until they eventually got caught now
when they got caught I believe they were
only 18 years old they were assessed by
psychiatrists who found that they were
disturbed right they thought that they
might be dangerous because of these
strange like delusions that they had and
and stuff like that so they said well we
don't want to put them in prison because
of their mental instability so they
ended up and I'm not sure this was
better but they ended up putting them in
Broadmoor which is a very famous
Hospital for the criminally insane
and the kind of sad thing about this is
that diary entries for the time like for
the girls that they wrote by the time
when they knew that they were going to
be sent to Broadmoor they kind of had
this romanticized vision of it like they
thought they were just gonna be sitting
out on the lawn at this hospital
drinking lemonade and writin in their
diary and stuff like that no Broadmoor
is where they said like the Yorkshire
Ripper that's where they sent like the
Kray brothers and stuff like you know
what I mean the gangsters and rapists
and serial you know but insane criminals
right so that's where these girls ended
up and it's kind of sad because the
documentary about them they actually
talked to one of the girls psychiatrists
at the time and he thought that it was
terrible that that's where they
it's it's almost kind of like they
didn't know what else to do with them at
the time they ended up the sad thing too
is that Broadmoor seems to have made
them worse yeah you know cuz they were
disturbed when they went in then they
lock him up and buzzer Lucius and they
separated them also ha ha so when that
happened one of them started getting
violent which they were really weren't
before I mean yeah breaking enter yeah
they were setting [__] on fire but they
weren't killing people they weren't
physically violent but when they were in
Broadmoor one of the girls did attack a
nurse and you know they were kind of
considered dangerous and stuff like that
now they were in Broadmoor for 11 years
they were there for 11 years and you
know their behavior just got kind of
weirder and weirder it's like you know
they they took turns eating like one of
them would eat one day and then starve
the next day and then that one would eat
one day and stuff like that and all this
other kind of stuff just all this kind
of weird behavior because like I said
they had this really strange their diary
entries they're just like kind of
portions of them online and stuff like
that but some of the stuff they wrote
about each other was very weird and
there was always like this perception
that Jennifer who was 10 minutes younger
was actually the more dominant twin and
so they think that maybe June was kind
of that Jennifer was maybe the one that
had developed this really bad mental
illness and that June was kind of like
going along with it sort of it you know
because there's kind of like a contagion
thing going on with twins and that kind
of plays into our next twin case too
because that was kind of a shared
psychosis the second thing also but you
know there's kind of this really strange
relationship between them like I because
there was some shift from Jennifer's
diary she writes about June they would
like beat up on each other like they
would punch each other of like one get
one guy said he saw them and they were
standing out in the yard like facing
each other and he said one would be like
you're Jennifer pow and then like she
would punch her in the arm then George
oon pow and the to like punch her in the
arm like that it was just like
really weird like relationship and in
their diary
you know June this was actually June
wrote talking about Jennifer she says
she wants us to be equal there's a
murderous gleam in her eye dear Lord I'm
scared of her she's not normal
someone is driving her insane it is me
you know what I mean like so this is
like a [__] this is a creepy [__]
story right this is like it's it's like
a horror movie but it's real then
Jennifer wrote in her diary about June
we have become fatal enemies in each
other's eyes we feel the irritating
deadly rays come out of our bodies
stinging each other's skin I say to
myself can I get rid of my own shadow
impossible or not possible without my
shadow would I die without my shadow
would I gain life be free or left to die
without my shadow which I identify with
a face of misery deception and murder so
it's like they were writing this [__]
about each other but they but they
didn't talk to anyone else except for
each other so it was like this weird
sick drive each other crazy
yeah like codependency and [__] like
that so then they get assessed like you
know like I said they're in Broadmoor
for 11 years and apparently you know as
crazy as it kind of made them after 11
years they were like well maybe it's
okay now that they can be transferred to
you know a lesser security hospital and
they were 29 at this point so they were
going to send them to this other
hospital in Bridgend
called Caswell clinic now apparently
before they went there
the twins decided that one of them was
going to have to die for the other one
to have a normal life and Jennifer
decided that she would she said she
would sacrifice herself this is this
came to light after Dan now what ended
up happening the day they came to
transfer the girls from Broadmoor to
Caswell and they pick up the two girls
and they put them in the bus and
Jennifer saying I don't really feel very
well and stuff like that she lays her
head on her sister's shoulder and then
she lays her her head on
sister's lap and she's laying there with
her eyes open they get to the Caswell
clinic and Jennifer is dead and they
have no [__] idea what she's not like
all they know that she died have they
said that she had like a sudden
inflammation of the heart they did an
autopsy no drugs no poison no nothing
like that
it was just like a sudden inflammation
of the heart and by the time they got
her to the other clinic she was dead she
ruled herself to die yeah that's what
they think and the weird thing about
that and then it came out afterward
because it was a journalist who kind of
befriended them you know later while
they were abroad Maura and she kind of
got a lot of stuff out of them and then
after Jennifer died you know June said
yeah we made a pact and Jennifer said
that she would die so I could have a
normal life and the weird thing is that
after Jennifer died Jun did have a
normal life - she just like she just
they said she started talking she
started acting normal eventually they
let her out she moved back to
Haverfordwest and Wales where her
parents were and she moved in next door
to her parents and just acted like a
normal person weird and I'm like this is
the [__] weirdest thing ever so it
was almost like good twin evil twin what
does something happening like on the
level of consciousness and quantum
consciousness yeah maybe there's one
consciousness inhabiting two bodies it
kind of something like that and it's and
then it's not that that's not right -
being divided between two bodies yeah
it's the same soul that phantom soul and
once and in some cases one of them has
to go so the other one could live that's
kind of weird because there's a lot of
normal twins out there that's what well
most of them are yeah well most of them
are normal I'd just crazy I guess these
two just crazy they drove each other
crazy yeah because like I said and and
this will I'm gonna talk about this
again like just makes me wonder is that
something paranormal does that have
something to do with it almost seems
weird enough to be paranormal that's I
mean this story is always like creeped
me out and it's like a sad story too
because it seems like I mean I guess
authorities of the time did everything
they could but it seemed like they
didn't really know how to deal with this
of mental illness that these girls are
suffering from at the time and it really
just seemed like stuff they did to help
them just kind of made things worse yeah
because they didn't really know how to
deal with it because it was so strange
and it was right you should I let him go
and tried to live a normal life that's
probably you know yeah yeah I mean like
I said when they separated them
sometimes they were just both going me
catatonia any boyfriends yeah well even
when they had those three boyfriends
that didn't help because then that they
got him into drugs and drinking well
guys maybe they wouldn't have that
problem that's what I mean they did they
fell it but like I said that was cuz
they kind of had that sort of like
obsession with criminality and all that
kind of stuff I think they they had like
a romantic perception of crime and a
being which seems like like I said they
don't want to still live yes Wow yeah
June is still alive and if she doesn't
he still lives in Wales yeah I don't
know it's like um like I said the last
thing I saw was from several years ago
where they were kind of looking into
need to get her on the chef it would be
fascinating I'm just like fascinated
were like wow like what the [__] was
going on maybe she can explain it better
now maybe she's older now and and
evidently she stalks them you know
because for a long time they couldn't
really get anything out of either one of
them right and they they did get a lot
of insight from you know a lot of the
stuff that they wrote in their Diaries
and things like that but just their
whole relationship seemed so weird and
so sick and it just seemed so strange
that Jennifer you know like I said she
was perceived as the more dominant twin
even though she was younger so it's
almost like she said well I'll sacrifice
myself so June can come out from beneath
my thumb or whatever it was just like
such a weird dynamic between them
probably nothing more than two shy
reclusive girls that happen to be twins
and because they're twins they have a
really good ability to drive each other
crazy
yeah that's what I mean is that's kind
of what fascinates me about their
imaginations were running away with yeah
it was just and it was just this extreme
love-hate relationship I crazy
do like they'd sit there just with each
other and come up with all these stories
and all that but it's just a [__]
it's a crazy crazy story and I'm
actually amazed they haven't made like
more movies about it or anything like
that but as you know I saw the
documentary on it which like I said it
was on a show called evil twins which I
guess is a on the Investigation
Discovery or whatever the [__] that
channel is and it seemed kind of it
seems sympathetic but you know the fact
that they kind of called it evil twins I
liked it it just seemed like a good
story yeah okay so we're at the halfway
point and we're gonna do a couple of
commercials now and then when we come
back I'm going to talk about another
crazy set of twins that this didn't end
quite so well we'll be back in just a
few minutes
[Music]
okay I'm we're back now the next set of
twins we're going to talk about maybe
you guys saw some of this footage this
happened back in 2008 and there's
actually a very good documentary um it
was on the BBC and I think you can find
it I found it on YouTube so I'm sure
dailymotion probably has it too is
called madness in the fast lane and it
has a lot of actual footage of the crazy
[__] story that kind of catapulted
these two sisters to worldwide notoriety
yeah I remember seeing him on the news
yeah I've done that freeway yeah this is
a crazy crazy story so these two women
Ursula and Sabina Eriksson now they were
originally from Sweden although in 2008
I believe Ursula was at Ursula that was
living in the United States and Sabina
I believe lived in Ireland with her
boyfriend and children now up to that
point
evidently they had been completely
normal individuals and you know living
apart they lived apart it's you know it
was fine they had normal lives yeah they
were what in 2008 I believe they were 40
okay she's a grown women news Broadway
grown as Lynn yeah now in 2008 the one
that lived in the United States which I
believe was Ursula I could be wrong or
whatever okay so she comes to Ireland to
visit her twin sister and for some
reason the two of them being back
together for I don't know how long they
had been apart prior to this but the two
of them being back together triggered
some type of crazy psychotic episode now
the first thing that happened was the
two women for some reason decided to get
on a bus and go to London they didn't
tell anyone why they were going or where
they were going or anything because
later on when they contacted Sabinas
boyfriend he's like I don't know I
didn't know where she went she just took
off her sister they said God so they get
on this bus now they stop at this here
we call it a rest stop it's motorway
services so they stopped at the motorway
services now they're acting very
strangely the bus drivers
says that they're clutching their bags
very close to their chest and they won't
let him take them to put him in the
storage compartment under the bus and
they're acting really sketchy okay so
he's like well I think I'm just gonna
leave him here because you know he
thought that there might be drugs or and
that they might be terrorists or who
knows you know they might have a [__]
bomb and they're they don't know so they
said well they just thought they were
acting weird so he's like well I'm you
know you can't get back on the bus so he
decides that he's gonna leave them there
now there was another woman who I guess
ran a shop at this motorway services and
she saw them and she said the same thing
she said they were acting really really
weird and they were like walking around
with these bags like clutched their
chests and they were like talking to
each other like all secretive and [__]
like that
and so she called the cops because she
thought they were acting so strangely
now the cops came and talked to them but
apparently didn't really find anything
amiss so the cops just left now after
the cops left these women apparently
decided that they were gonna take off on
foot so they start walking down like the
the middle of like the freeway there's
you know like a median anything right
now
they're walking down the video which
you're not really supposed to do so you
know because it's dangerous so they they
saw them on CCTV cameras so they sent a
cop to see if they were all right so the
cops get there and one of the sisters
goes booking in a traffic manager yeah
and she kind of gets hit by one car but
she's fine and then she kind of gets hit
a clip by another car and she's fine and
[__] like that so then you know everyone
starts calling for backup this is -
there's this woman and she's running
around on the m6 so luckily for us or
perhaps not so hopefully when the main
cops arrived at the scene it just so
happened that there was a camera crew
and they were doing a ride-along for the
British equivalent of the American show
cops or some motorway cops so they had a
whole camera crew like a TV crew
following along with the cops I saw
yes oh the cops they're in the car and
you can see them and all they know is
that there's a woman running around in
traffic and that she might have gotten
hit by a car so they need to go and
check out what's going on so they pull
up and there's already one cop there and
the sister Sabina is fun she's like
standing there talking to the cops or
something like that then you know both
the sisters are fine they're standing
there talking to the police now all of a
sudden and you can see this very clearly
on the footage because the TV footage is
right there and it's in the documentary
it's a little disturbing
suddenly Ursula just takes off into
traffic now one of the cops tries to
grab her but she shrugs out of her
jacket and runs in and she gets hit by a
[__] truck yeah and goes under the
wheels yeah so they immediately they
think she's dead it did look like she
got killed actually and the weird thing
too is that she when she runs out in
traffic like Sabina is like kind of
standing there just smoking a cigarette
or something like that and she just goes
oh look at that you know kind of think
where the cops are like what the [__]
and then Sabina runs into traffic yeah
and she gets hit by a car
and it throws her and you can see this
on the footage to it she hits the the
hood and the windshield and part of the
roof and then kind of flies off and hits
the road and they showed the car
afterward the windshield is busted the
roof is all dented in and [__] like that
so she got hit hard yeah okay it gets
better from what I remember oh my god
yeah this is the [__] crazy and and
like I said you're you see the footage
in this documentary and you just can't
believe it yeah it's just unbelievable
and you and they interviewed the cops
like who were there and they couldn't
believe it there was like what the [__]
like you could hear them yelling but I
was like what the hell is so it look
like suicide they're not winnings well
that's what they thought they thought
maybe it was well first thing that was
drugs but um you know because they said
maybe they're on PCP or meth or
something we don't know or they thought
it was a suicide pact
the crazy thing so the cops go and they
to tend to Ursula now the cop says he's
like obviously her legs are crushed
like there's bone sticking out and
everything like that if I remember
correctly it wasn't part of the leg leap
left out into the road
no okay no but the wheels went over like
you know from pretty much her thighs
down um were squished yeah and so there
he said there's bones sticking out and
everything like that he's like so
obviously you know she but she was still
conscious right now Sabina who had been
hit by the other car she was knocked out
for a little bit but then she woke up
now
Ursula even though she couldn't get up
because her legs were crushed
she starts spitting at the cops yeah I
remember that and say I know who you are
I know you're not real and then she
yells - her sister they're gonna steal
your organs something like yeah yeah
yeah I remember that yeah right so
they're like screaming they're like
fighting the cops and her legs are
crushed she's laying in the room with
her legs crushed and she's like spitting
at the cops and she'll like that and
he's like he's like love just calm down
we're trying to help you you're hurt and
all this other stuff and she's just you
know good and then she's like yelling
like call the police he's like we are
the police
yeah
[Music]
so then Sabina who had been knocked out
and like I said broke the [__]
windshield his card ended the hood and
everything like that she gets up and
looks totally fine alright and she
starts hauling ass into the road again
and the other cops are like chaser down
gone hey you know please don't you know
an ambulance is coming and stuff and she
just starts yelling and she punches one
of the cops and then climbs over the
guardrail and goes running across the
other side of the motorway like the
other people going and they're just like
flipping out he he's like you know not
only are these girls you know these
women hurt he's like but you know they
there could cause accidents like a
motorway we're trying to you know
contain the situation right so a couple
of good Samaritans who had been stopped
I got out of cars and kind of helped the
cops wrestle this chick cuz the guy was
like this woman he's like this is why
initially they thought they were on
drugs or something like that he's like
because this woman was unbelievably
strong right it took six people to
subdue her I mean she
was flipping out and they they kind of
like her and she was just like screaming
ha ha call the police and he's like we
are the police that she was like she's
flipping out and finally they got her to
the other side of the carriageway and
they kind of they strapped her arms and
legs everything she's still screaming
and everything like that and suddenly
the end stuff finally the ambulance gets
there and they sedate her cuz they're
like you know obviously we can't take it
like this because she's just like she's
hulking out all right so okay so Ursula
the one whose legs were crushed
obviously they have to take her the
hospital she's in critical condition
even though she was still conscious and
she was yelling and spitting at the cops
and everything like that yeah [__] man
uh-huh so Sabina they sedated her they
took her to the hospital she was in the
hospital for five hours they checked her
out she didn't have any major injuries
unbelievably also no drugs or alcohol on
her system so they were kind of
surprised they checked out Ursula so
also no drugs in her system or alcohol
either so what happened that's what I
mean no one knows no one else so but oh
it gets better
okay so they let Sabina out of the
hospital after five hours because she
doesn't have any major major injuries
even though she just got [__] hit by
a car and thrown around like a rag doll
as you can see on the video now they
take her to the police station afterward
because you know she's kind of you know
obstructing traffic she had a cop and
all this other stuff he shouldn't hit
her hard but you know she kind of pushed
her over so they take her there and they
keep her in custody for a couple of days
and they have you know psychiatrists
come and talk to her they have other you
know the cops come and talk to her and
everything like that and they actually
since the the TV crew was still kind of
following this story for the show they
actually have a lot of footage of Sabina
at the police station now when she's in
the police station and this to me is
like the creepiest part of the whole
thing she's acting totally normal
she's totally normal and they said out
like all the cops and everything like
that we're talking to her and everything
they said you know she was seemed like a
little odd but not crazy not you know
she was acting totally she was a Templar
with the cop and like Oh how does my
hair look she's acting totally totally
normal and I mean the only weird things
she said and they have her on tape
saying this she says something like Oh
in Sweden we say that it's never just
one accident there's always gonna be
another one maybe two all right like
that was the weirdest thing she said but
most of the other [__] she said was like
totally normal now the cops found it odd
that she did not ask about her sister at
all
he said she just seemed kind of
concerned about because she was kind of
just still in a hospital gown and she
was kind of mad because she had to take
her jewellery off and she's like I don't
look pretty anymore in that kind that
kind of thing he's like she seemed to
kind of you know self-centered right but
not weird not crazy or anything like
that she's acting totally normal
so they kept her in custody for a couple
of days and they said well she seems
fine the psychiatrist said she seemed
fine she seemed normal so they let her
go now the next day she goes to
stoke-on-trent and she's walking down
the street these two guys that had been
drinking at a pub they noticed her they
said she kind of stood out she had this
big puffy jacket on and they said she
had like all of her belongings like in
this clear plastic bag and he said she
looked lost you know like she was in
trouble or something like that and they
were walking a dog and they were kind of
like hey you all right or something cuz
she said something she's like oh that's
a nice dog or something like that so
they whenever started talking to her and
she told them she's like oh my sister's
in the hospital and I have to find out
where she is so I can go see her and
then she asked them she's like is there
a bed-and-breakfast around here and they
were like oh you know not around here
something like that now one of the guys
Glenn Hollinshead who was 54 years old
he said well you know he's like why
don't you come to my place I'll you know
make a cup of tea I'll give you
something to eat and you know we can
find out where your sister is and I'll
find you a place to stay good samaritan
yeah so so Glenn and his friend Peter
Malloy who he was with they take Sabina
back to Glenn's house now Peter Malloy
they interviewed him for the documentary
and he said you know he's like the girl
was acting or the woman was acting a
little weird to start with but it was
nothing alarming
now they said the only thing that
started to get weird was when they
started drinkin together and stuff like
that
he said now she had been smoking
cigarettes pretty much all evening he's
like she takes out the bot the pack of
cigarettes again and she offers each of
them one so they take one they put it in
their mouths and then all of a sudden
she snatches him out of their mouth and
she says don't smoke that they could be
poisoned and Peter Malloy is like she's
been smoking those all day and he's like
why would they be poison they're your
cigarettes or something like that and
then he said she started acting like
super paranoid like she was like looking
out the window like she was looking for
something and so at this stage Peter is
like okay well I'm hot enough of this
action so he left
now she ended up staying over at Glenn's
house like sleeping on the couch or
whatever and he said okay well in the
morning I'm gonna call around and find
out where your sister is and I'll drop
you off to visit her or whatever okay so
the next day all I know it happened okay
so the name so Glenn's neighbor said he
sees Glenn come out so Glenn's neighbor
is in the in the back alley he was like
washing his car or something Glenn comes
out and asked if he could borrow tea
bags right so he gives him some tea bags
he goes back in the house less than two
minutes later Glenn comes back out the
house and says she stabbed me
mm and he's bleeding just all over the
place so the neighbors like haha [__]
like so the neighbors like calling the
cops and the neighbor says Glenn's like
I'm dying I'm dying and the guys like
you know I got a guy and it's alright
and stuff like that and he said then
Glenn said will you take care of my dog
alright wish it I just thought that was
really horrible cuz like the old man was
like the size of his old guy that lived
next door and he was like anything he's
gonna die I mean I mean but he did die
right there and I yeah he blended up and
they said yeah care of my dog yeah
that's um awesome I was like oh my god
that's horrible okay and then so
evidently before the cops could get
there or anything like that there then
there was this guy who was driving down
the street by there and he saw a woman
running down the street she was carrying
a hammer and she was hitting herself in
the head
it with a hammer yeah like she was wet
and he said there was blood all over her
head her hair was all matted so he
pulled over like to try to help her all
right
he's like what's the matter with you
what's the matter and she hit him on the
back of the head he's like at first I
thought it was with her fist all right
um
he's like but later it was determined
that she had a roof tile in her pocket
did she hit him in the back of the head
with a roof tile well you might have you
might have to you might need a roof time
you never know when you might need that
[__] right so at this stage the cops
were coming and they saw her running now
she ran away from the cops and she was
on an overpass and she it was 40 feet
over the highway
she jumped off damn and she lived wow
this is like [__] she's like Robocop
yeah these [__] are like Robocop say
that yeah so she jumps off all habits
she broke her ankles and she fractured
her skull but she lived yeah so finally
and her sister's still laying up in a
hospital yeah okay doesn't know anything
that's the idea this is gone so finally
these [__] are crazy so they catch
they finally catch Davina and they put
her on trial for murder
we're killing Milan Hollinshead like you
do now she was assessed by several
psychiatrists both for the prosecution
and for the defense
both psychiatrists found that she was
not entirely culpable they made
different diagnoses but they were
similar one of them said that she was
suffering from what they call fully a
dude which is madness shared by to which
it's a very rare disorder yeah but it
happens when you are in proximity to
someone who has a mental illness and it
infects you how is that very possible
it does happen like I said it's very
rare and it's not just between it's not
necessarily just happening between so
they're they're crazy behavior drives
you crazy yeah okay so it's not by a
virus no no
I'm saying infected in a metaphorical
sense and the other one called it Buffay
dealt oh [__]
which actually means it kind of means
delirious flash or I've also heard it
translated as a puff of madness Jesus
essentially temporary insanity now
because these women had no prior history
of mental illness and it only happened
when they got together right and then
afterward they found no mental illness
in either one of them they both acted
completely normal after because she
described how happen well the thing
about Sabina is that when they put her
on trial yes she subjected herself to
you know the psychiatrists assess her
and stuff like that she would not speak
in her own defense she basically just
said no comment no comment no comment
she said nothing even during the
evaluations I don't know about that they
just said in the trial she didn't speak
in her defense she wouldn't say anything
she just wouldn't comment so no one
really knows what the deal was but like
I said when she was assessed they didn't
find any trace of mental illness same
thing with Ursula so what happened her
they actually um the judge wanted to he
said well she has she was eventually
convicted of manslaughter because it was
diminished responsibility right the
judge actually wanted to put her away
for an indeterminate amount of time is
that well because he wanted he said well
I want to make sure that she's safe
before she's let out all right but
because there was some kind of legal
thing where they couldn't really do that
because now she's not mentally ill and
stuff like that she ended up only
serving five years as far as I know and
she was business UK she was supposedly
let out on parole in 2011 I haven't
heard anything about her since then I'm
pretty sure she went back to Sweden
after she was let out and I think Ursula
was the one whose legs were crushed she
was in the hospital for three months and
then when she got out she went back to
the US and as far as I know neither one
of them have exhibited any of this type
of
five years for that that's [__] that's
only the UK does it go down well the
family of the u.s. Louisiana forty years
she got a 40 yeah well the family of the
family of the guy that was murdered were
upset they said they understood that
yeah she was crazy and stuff like that
but they're like you know he's like that
they talked to the guy's brother like on
the documentary he's like you know oh my
brother doesn't get to have a life and
they just have to go back to what they
were you could have a brain tumor in
your head in the United States and they
go well you did it we can't trust you
we're gonna kill you well yeah that's it
and I think people had good comment like
us on some of the YouTube videos show
like they did just shot you here yeah
crazy that means we're gonna have to
kill you
yeah it's like it's weird because it
seems like in the case of the silent
twins these two were put in [__]
Broadmoor when they probably didn't need
to be yeah and then in the case of these
two it was kind of like they were they
were kind of let go when they probably
should she's crazy let her go I mean
yeah I mean like I said obviously she
didn't seem crazy or they wouldn't or
they wouldn't have let her go but you
know yeah you don't know what people are
gonna do but she seemed normal but I
don't know and like I said that was the
creepiest thing to me is when they
showed the footage of her in the police
station she did seem totally no I
wouldn't have thought she was presence
in crazy at all but yeah so that was
kind of weird but it's weird because
shared psychosis like I said it is a
thing it's very rare they talk to a guy
on the documentary who was kind of like
a big clinical psychologist and stuff he
said I've assessed like 500 600 cases or
so like that my career he's like I have
come across one case of that of Foley I
do where it's where it's a shared
psychosis because if they said it
happens a lot
they said it usually happens with
siblings they're very close like twins
happens with married couples that are
unusually close or within very close
families they said it can happen in a
whole family and actually there's a case
in Australia I think they're called the
Trump family tier OMP I think is their
names and there's a case in Australia
going on
it's either still going on or it was
going on last year so I was just reading
about it in the in the Australian paper
that it was a whole family and they said
it's you
the dad flips out first it's usually
like paranoid delusions they think you
know aliens are gonna get them or the
government is out to get them or
something like that and it'll rub off on
like the wife and kids and that's what
faulty information into other people and
then you know do that over a long period
of time yeah you know that faulty
information kind of adds up and that
person becomes faulty I guess yeah and
especially if you don't have a lot of
interaction with normal people right I
think it happens a lot like in Isis like
relationships that are isolated like I
said it probably happened in the case of
the silent twins because I didn't really
lose intensely evil because humans are a
social species I mean I'm actually
surprised it doesn't happen more often
but it does but it is very rare it also
they think it also might have happened
you don't remember that actor Randy
Quaid no okay Randy Quaid you some of
the listeners might rely he was oh he is
it was Dennis Quaid's brought their like
less famous brother he was in a bunch of
movies who's kind of a comedian in 2010
him and his wife apparently have this
shared psychosis thing they think that
there is a cabal of assassins called
Star whackers okay yeah who are trying
to assassinate him and he thinks that
these star walkers were responsible for
the murders of David Carradine and Heath
Ledger okay that both Heath Ledger and
David Carey killed by Star Wars yeah
yeah and they think that do they have
any special offenses they have to wear
to be a star whacker
right now I'm now I wonder uniform but
it was like a ship outfit I hope so yeah
with a star with a star with a with a no
sign over it lack robes
yes so Randy Quaid a parent I didn't
know about this until I started research
of this but I felt like I was like Randy
Quaid what happened to him oh okay he
thinks he's important enough to stop
someone would want assassinate him and
his wife and apparently it rubbed off on
his wife to Kadesh now she believes I
should also so like I said this story
they probably never know the two women
are still alive far as I know I think
sabina is back in sweden now hasn't made
a peep I think Ursula went back to the
US because that's where she lived and I
don't think she's made a peep either and
currently they're fine yeah he keeps
coming back six don't it is it six sir I
thought it was more than that yeah the
peeps of blue peeps they make all colors
how about pink peeps that's a good story
though Jenny yeah well thank you very
much I didn't make it up or anything
like that
okay well you know truth is stranger
than fiction that's what that's it all
right so we're getting to the end of the
show hope you enjoyed this again
rambling we're always rambling yeah I
guess that's why people like this though
yeah I got a little bit of a headache so
I couldn't ramble all that much no oh
man that's a good one anyway so that'll
do it for episode 61 if you like the
show please remember to Like share
subscribe and all that other kind of
stuff share around on your social media
you know get other people listening to
the show term onto it and also if you'd
like to support the show you can go to
our patreon page which is at 13 o'clock
podcast and give us a monthly donation
if you would rather give a one-time
donation rather than monthly donation
you can go to our blog which is I don't
blow it is 13 o'clock podcasts out
WordPress com I think that's right
and there's a little PayPal link on the
sidebar so you can just click on that
and give us a bucket to buy a cup of
coffee that'd be nice and also be sure
to check out our last movie review which
was xcalibur
and send us your Halloween stories for
the Halloween special which is coming up
in a couple of weeks and that'll do it
for this episode see you next Tuesday
[Music]
you